- All right, we've got a super sweet story
to close out this hour.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
This past Christmas, a
grandma in New York decided
to create her very own cookbook
made of her signature dishes.
She wanted to ensure her
family had their favorite meals
for a long time to
come, which is so sweet.
Once she put it all together,
she realized she needed cover art,
so she turned to her granddaughter, Kate.
And here's what Kate came up with.
It is so rad.
Kate's painting has TikTok buzzing
with over half a million views
and we have her on the line right now
watching on News Channel 13 in Albany.
Hi Kate.
- Hey, Kelly.
- You are so talented.
And so cool.
It's such cool cover art.
So this project was
something your grandma wanted
for a long time, right?
- Yeah, I mean, honestly, as
far back as I can remember
my family's always going
over to my grandma's house
for Sunday dinner and I come from like
I'm at one of six kids,
so my grandma knows how to
like pull out all the stops
and cook for all of us.
And the cookbook idea,
I mean we've all encouraged her to do it
through the years, but this
past year, my sister, Emma,
really got the ball going.
A couple of family members
helped with assembly,
and at the end she asked
me to do the cover.
But it was a secret,
because we wanted to
surprise everyone else
like with the finished product.
And I ended up filming it on TikTok,
and then the response
to that was so sweet,
just like people saying, "Oh,
I wish I could have done
this with my grandma."
People saying like, "Oh,
you've inspired me."
Other people like wanting
a copy of the book.
So, that stuff has just been so cool.
- Oh my god, it is so cool.
What a cool family thing to do together.
- Yeah.
- To make sure that you honor your grandma
by getting every detail just right.
Tell us about the process.
Like there was a photo
shoot and everything, right?
- Oh, yeah.
So step one, I bossed my poor
grandma around in her kitchen
and took a bunch of pictures
of different things around
her kitchen to inspire me.
And I came up with a
sketch, went from there.
And my favorite part is
all the details we included
from her actual house.
So it's like her geese
wallpaper in the back,
her actual cookie jar, her
geese salt and pepper shakers,
her actual dog, all that kind of stuff.
And when my family got to see it,
it was a big surprise
for a bunch of people.
And everyone loved all those details.
So it's just so cool
that it's finished now.
We can have it forever, and I don't know,
I'm really proud to
have been a part of it.
- It's so cool.
It's a way to have your grandma with you
for the rest of your life.
That's an amazing thing.
- Yes.
- You are very cool by the way.
Your whole look is so
cute and rock and roll.
I love it.
- Kelly.
- Oh my god, you're
wearing a onesie as well.
You're so cute.
Thank you so much, Kate.
I'm liking your post and you right now.
(audience cheering)
And that's not all, girl.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- [Kate] Kelly, no, they're not.
- Thank you so much, Kate,
for sharing your family with us
and thank you to all our guests this hour:
Seal, Ava Max, Becky
Lynch, and Courtney Rich.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.